hello everyone and welcome back to the
1972 World Chess Championship match
between Robert James Fischer and Boris
positive it's baski it's a game 17 and
Fischer is still three points in the
lead as possibly however again has the
white pieces and it's very interesting
how he will continue continue this match
and now games are on the board are very
intense but if you've been following the
series so far you know that there is an
entire match going on behind the boards
as during Game 15 in 16 the entire hole
has been surrounded with police officers
so the viewers even said that the the
playing call actually looks a lot more
impressive now with all of these
Icelandic police officers there and the
the Russian committee disassembled the
Fisher's chair and they didn't find
anything but even though it was a fiasco
it did give the reporters something to
write about
and although the experts and the
audience and people who were kind of
more into chess than your regular
reviewer were enjoying this chess very
much as it really was a you know a chess
spectacle it was not all that easy to
keep the viewers reading about this
match all around the world with the
moves only so the the chess reporters
really loved everything Fischer did I
even though it annoyed everyone in
Spassky scam but yeah now that being
said let's check out this game as it
again features an opening that Fischer
never before played in his entire life
so without further ado Spassky plays
efore and we have d6 so Fischer goes for
the Paris defense d4 and now g6 sorry
about that it seems I have blundered the
sound in the previous video as so many
of you have said nice to f6 is also
possible here but Fischer prefers this
g6 idea as it leaves black a lot more
options how to develop Knights the c3
spastically decides the first play
Knight to c3 instead of Knight to f3 and
leave this option of playing f4 if
needed
Knight to f6
official transposes into the mainline
and now comes F for the trip the g7 and
now comes nice to f3 again in the
mainline and this is not the Austrian
attack
well F for was the Austrian the start of
the Austrian attack this is simply
continuing with the Theory c5 and this
was a less known move at the time and
the Fischer did it so perhaps this Posse
would not be so at home with this
variation and although II 5 seems
somewhat interesting here not really if
I've seems like an attacking move but
all you've done is a given black a
target after 97 this point is now
attacked three times and you do have to
do something about it but you haven't
really achieved it anything eise Ickx
doesn't really do anything if Knight g5
going after the point simply Knight back
to f6 the pawn is defended always well
for black white is down upon so not
nothing really to show for after this if
DK person c5 you can regain a pawn
button and black will simply capture and
ignore you
after c5 d captures on c5 by Spassky we
have Queen to a5 now if you play D
captures on c5 immediately then Queen
capture scheme captures and E 5 will be
a really amazing position for white
after Knight moves Knight g5 is coming
going after f7 and after you defend this
for example Knight to h6 then Bishop to
e3 is coming and you have an excellent
position here for white where all of the
pieces are simply developing on itself
the position basically plays itself so
after D captures on c5 Fischer first
goes Queen to a5 going after the c5 pawn
and here Bishop to d3 Spassky doesn't
mind giving back the pawn Queen captures
on c5 now preventing Spassky from
castling and now comes Queen to e2
guarding d3 square and preparing Bishop
to e3 Fischer castles now we have Bishop
to e3 and now comes Queen to a5 who felt
at one game played Queen to c7
instead of Queen to a5 here and it seems
to be also a very nice idea but
spassky's idea is also also great
we have castles and now comes Bishop to
g4 pinning the night and
this was considered to be the best idea
for black rook a 2d one Spassky develops
the rook and now comes Knight to c6 and
here Bishop to c4 here all of a sudden
Spassky now both places this Bishop on
this very strong diagonal and transposes
into a very attacking formation first
goes
Knight to h5 it's a it's an excellent
move because it immediately asks what
are you doing with this Knight and
although it seems a bit weird to give up
your strong dark square Bishop your
dragon for this night and even a pawn
but it seems to work in this position
and here's puska plays a very nice
attacking move Bishop to b3 to
understand why Bishop to b3 is an
excellent attacking move you first we
first have to see what happens if rook
to d5 is played this comes with an
attack on the Queen and also after the
Queen moves
perhaps the screen to c7 when we
mentioned that GU felt played this
against al I was better because it
doesn't allow any ideas such as this
about okay now comes rook to g5
attacking the bishop
but this doesn't work because of Bishop
captures on f3 queen cap clean captures
sorry G captures rook captures on f3 and
now Knight to d4 with an attack against
the Queen and the rook after Bishop
captures Bishop captures with Czech as
you don't want to be down the exchange
King to h1 now black has Knight to f4
this was Fisher's idea because now you
see the bishop on c4 is guarded by the
Queen but there is another problem rook
captures on f4 and now Bishop captures
in c3b captures on c3 and now comes D 5
your rook is under attack and also now
there is a double attack against the
bishop on c4 so if you have to protect
the rook more most likely and then D
captures on c4
black wins back the piece he's up upon
and he has a better position as a
White's pawn structure is severely
compromised so that's why Bishop to b3
is simply getting the bishop away from
c4 so Fisher doesn't have this c5 this
d5 discovery in the future we have
Bishop captures on c3 a Fischer doesn't
wait for Spassky to go
disruptor d5 idea now is now this is
definitely a possibility but by playing
this possibly also gives up a pawn
Fischer accepts it Bishop captures pawn
captures and now Queen captures on c3
and here we have f5 sorry by white f5
Knight back to f6 official now did
everything there needed to be done with
this night on h5 and now he wants to
regain control of the central squares h3
to unpin against this Knight you do have
to force black that to either capture or
well now he has to capture before page 5
is obviously not happening Bishop
captures Queen captures and now comes
Knight to a5 Fischer's now finds a very
clever idea he wants to get rid of this
very strong light square Bishop Spassky
has an b3 whereas this Knight to e5 move
coming with an attack against the Queen
doesn't isn't all that impressive
because here Queen to f4 and white will
get a very strong attack if the Queen
comes manages to find her way to h6 so
after Queen to f3 we have
Knight to a5 and now comes Rock to d3
attacking Fisher's Queen Queen back to
c7 and now comes Bishop to h6 here
Spassky decided at least I'm gonna try
and be materialistic here as I've pretty
much run out of any other options
Knight capture some b3 Fischer grabs the
very strong light square Bishop and here
you don't have the option of capturing
at f8 really because official will
simply move the knight and attack your
rook
so now you can't really give up this
very strong Bishop it controls all of
the dark squares here you would have to
move the bishop and now after Knight
captures pawn captures the material now
will be equal you know a pieces y so the
black will still be up upon but black
will be in a better position here
so after Knights the b3 we have C
capture son b3 by Spassky and the now
comes Queen to c5 with check here as
Paschal if King to h1 automatically but
glitch says that instead of this King to
h1 move rook to e3
was a better defensive resource because
it saves a temple in the future but it's
it doesn't appear to be so because here
after spastics King to H one official
played Queen to e5 he decided to give up
the exchange here and okay Spassky
accepted this he played the Bishop
captures and I faith we have rook
captures on f8 and now because the
knight and Queen are attacking the e4
point you do have to protect it so now
Spassky play the rook to e3 but this is
the reason why Liguori says that this
King to h1 was a waste of a temple that
rook to e3 was better
straight straight away but the problem
is after rook to e3 in this position
straight away who knows if Fisher would
have gone for the same exchange
sacrifice with Queen to e5 perhaps he
would simply move the rook rook after c8
and now the game continues white does
have does have a very strong attack but
after g4 there's no there's no immediate
anything that white has black but should
be able to fend off this attack but okay
I'm sure glitch definitely had something
there King to h1 we have Queen to d5 as
we've said Fisher offers a rope Bishop
captures rook captures and now comes
look to e3 defending d4 pawn as we've
mentioned rope the c8 and this is a
Fisher's compensation he has a night
against the rook but this rook is not a
very impressive rook he start guarding
d4 pawn and into the night is a very
impressive piece on the other hand
Fischer has the sole control of the only
open file the C file on the board and as
you can see this efore opponent as we've
already said and if this rook manages to
infiltrate as passkeys second rank this
point will become weak as well so down
the exchange but to definitely has
compensation f captures on g6 by Spassky
we have H captures on g6 and now Queen
to f4
Spassky is ready to either infiltrate
with the Queen to h6 or offer a queen
trade and here spassky's hoping that he
will somehow be able to activate the
ropes but
says that he you will not Queen captures
we have rook captures on f4 and now
comes as spassky's threatening a five
this would be very dangerous and it
would create more open files for the
rook so Fisher stops at nightly seven
getting the Knight to e5
rook to f2 and now comes Knight to e5
King to h2 we have looked the c1 a very
nice idea
now the Fisher will be able to use the
last rank to attack spot attacks
passkeys weaknesses here even though
this prevented the infiltration via the
second ranked rook et2 here Spassky is
hoping for rook to c2 to either exchange
a pair of rooks but if not that then he
will at least be able to infiltrate
Fischer's position really the open sea
file so Knight to c6 Fisher closes of
the sea file and now he doesn't really
care what Spassky does along the sea
file
rook the c2 and now simply rook to e1
fishery declines the trade of rooks as
if he traded drugs then you would have a
rock against tonight of course what
would be much better here most likely
even winning but the Fisher wants to use
this rook he has the keep attacking
Spassky spassky's weaknesses by going
back and forth rook F to e to we have a
rope to a 1 and now King to g3
King to g7 rook C to D to look to f1
rook blocks rook we have rook to e1 and
down rook to e2 look to f1 and here look
to e3 Spassky doesn't want to repeat the
position three times and allow a draw by
threefold repetition and Fischer goes a6
we would have looked the c3 and now rook
to e1 we have roped the c4 and here by
this points past his position has
improved his rooks are much more active
but still there is not all that much he
can do you can go 95 to force the rook
off of the fourth-ranked to capture a
pawn because you would simply allow a
white rope to activate that's not
something you want to do so rook to f1
fish or simply keeps going back and
forth
rook D to C 2 and now look to a1 we have
looked to f2 and here this is move 40
here the game was adjourned Spassky hat
see off his 41st move and it's very
interesting the next day when they
arrived at the board rook to e1 sorry
hereafter rook to e1 the game was
adjourned and I was pasty had to seal
the move and he sealed rook F to c2 and
it was a very interesting because now
even Spassky steam they complained to
the chief arbiter lot of Schmidt and
said that for the next game Fischer has
the car it has the bidder on time
because official was never on time well
very rarely he was on time for the game
but he was almost never on time for the
continuation of the adjourned games so
Schmidt said the Fischer has to come and
this was the first game that Fischer was
actually on time for the adjourned game
and he was you know greeted with
applause for that
so Fischer played g5 this is the move he
prepared overnight and it seems like an
order move why would you do this well it
is explained the explanation is twofold
at some point white might actually get
the idea to play rook captures on c6
because Spassky can always draw this
game and Fischer can never win this game
only Spassky can put this for the wind
so we spy if Spassky really wants to
play for the win
at some point he might consider playing
rope captures went back the night and
grabbed a pawn by doing so and also then
he will perhaps be able to snatch off
the pawns on the Queen side but it will
still be very hard because also White
has weak bones but by doing this g5 move
he's actually grabbing a lot more space
on the kingside are restricting the
movements of the White King and perhaps
in the future East 6 and f5 will be very
strong already creating a very strong
opponent presence on the King side and
also if White doesn't go for this then
it simply freeze the g6 Square for what
for black's knight if it might become
needed in the future so very nice here
we have looked the c1 by Spassky
offering a rook trade we'll have looked
to e2 and now comes again rook want to
see two rook to e1 we have looked the c1
look to e2 and again rook 1 to c2 and
Fisher here called a chief arbitrage MIT
and he told him Spassky with he
look 1 2 c2 repeated the position three
times and here a Fisher claimed a draw
by threefold repetition so it's very
unclear I it wasn't only at the time I
don't know if it is no now why Spassky
did this he could have pushed for the
win there were a lot of things he could
have tried and it's probably he wouldn't
just agree to a draw here because he can
never lose this game and he's already
down three points in the match so
perhaps what happened to him was the
same thing that happened Tigran
Petrosian was he when he was playing
against Bobby Fischer one game he he
drew by threefold repetition on accident
he accidentally repeated the position
three times so well this is what could
have happened also another explanation
is that passkey simply spent an entire
night with his team and then they
couldn't figure out how to win this
position would white because they mean
there is no win but well it's hard to
say but yeah that's the game at the
score is now 10 to 7 and some of you
were asking in the comments how many
games are there in this match I don't I
never announced this because for those
of you who don't know how many games is
there are in this match I thought it
would be perhaps more interesting not to
know but if you're really interested
some some may not want to know of course
you can always google it it's not really
a secret but there there aren't a lot
more will very very soon will be over
with this series so yeah that's game 17
I do hope you enjoyed it as it's the
first time Fischer played the Pearce
defense it was the first time well maybe
maybe he played it like once during
simultaneous exhibitions but not in
series tournament play and it was the
first time Fischer was on time well for
the continuation of the adjurned game
and again a very very attacking games by
Spassky but you know it just wasn't
meant to be
so yeah 10 to 7 I would also like to
thank Kenneth McKay of Scotland thank
you for contributing to my channel
really appreciate it
as usual you can check too on my
previous videos here think all for
watching and I'll see you soon hopefully
with some more interesting content thank
you all and I'll see you soon